So before we go on to the next major computer
science topic we're going to introduce. I want to give you
one more quiz, to see if you can write a python
expression that's going to give you some idea how fast a
computer executes. So your goal for this quiz is to write
some python code that will print out how far light travels
in one nanosecond. Let me give you some information that will
help with this. So, the speed of light is 299,792,458 meters
per second. So, almost 300 million.
One meter is 100 centimeters. One nanosecond is one billionth of a second.
Which is 1 divided by 1000 000 000.
So, your goal is to compute how far light travels in one nanosecond,
and to get that answer in centimeters. And I don't want this to be
an algebra quiz. So, all you need to do is multiply
these three values together, and you'll get the answer we want.